It's a sad, cinematic truth: many movies are
nowhere near as entertaining as their epic,
exciting trailers suggest.
What are trailers but semi-spoilery commercials
designed to get butts in seats anyhow?
Once that thrilling, transcendent trailer
lures you into a sticky theater with a bucket
of popcorn under your arm, you find out the
horrible truth.
Here are just a few epic trailers that were
wasted on disappointing movies.
Prometheus
After 15 years away from the Alien franchise,
Prometheus promised to be a ground-breaking
return to form for director Ridley Scott.
Plus, we'd totally get to see, like, billions
of xenomorphs, right?
Or see where they came from?
Maybe have coffee with that Space Jockey guy?
He seemed cool.
The first trailer does an amazing job reminding
the audience of just how awesome the Aliens
franchise can be, despite its long time out
of theaters and that whole Alien versus Predator
thing.
The name Prometheus fades in just like in
Alien, and we slowly catch glimpses of elements
from the original movie.
In the space of one minute, it's a masterclass
in visual storytelling, and tons of trailers
have copied the same format.
But despite average to positive reviews, Prometheus
never hit the same highs as Alien, and it
just left audiences with even more questions.
Judging by the trailer, however, it could
have been much, much more.
And would it kill Ridley Scott to throw in
a few more xenomorphs?
The Phantom Menace
In the dark ages before YouTube, watching
movie trailers was hard.
You had to know which films the trailers were
attached to, and hope your theater was showing
the right ones.
When the trailer for The Phantom Menace dropped,
fans were so hyped that they bought tickets
to other movies just to see the trailer, not
even staying for the movie afterwards.
All through November 1998, theaters sold out
tickets to movies like A Bug's Life, only
to have seats empty out before the opening
titles even rolled.
We all know how The Phantom Menace turned
out, but the trailer was actually really good.
The opening shot of a fog-covered swamp with
the Force Theme is still spine-tingling.
The visuals look awesome, and even the awkward
Yoda lines feel epic.
It's so good that it almost makes us want
to go back and watch Episode I again.
Almost.
In the Heart of the Sea
Whaling doesn't top many lists of "Things
There Aren't Enough Movies About," but In
the Heart of the Sea looked like it was ready
to change that.
This trailer had everything: beautiful cinematography,
cool special effects shots, some kind of secret
water monster, and Thor looking badass holding
a spear!
What's not to love?
The trailer was so good that at least four
million people watched it on purpose, many
of whom never even knew they wanted to see
a whaling movie.
Unfortunately, the only good things about
the movie were all packed into the trailer.
Despite being stocked with talented actors
and having Ron Howard in the director's chair,
the film never connected with the audience.
It earned a meager 42% on Rotten Tomatoes,
with reviewers mostly calling the film boring,
unconvincing, and dry.
Which is saying something, considering the
movie takes place in the water.
In the end, all it did was prove that not
even Chris Hemsworth's rippling muscles can
save a sinking ship.
Battle: Los Angeles
Most movie trailers are just made of attractive
scenes slapped together in some kind of coherent
order, but a few become pieces of art on their
own.
Battle: Los Angeles is pure trailer art.
Opening with shots of UFO sightings from around
the world, it gave us a feast of the best
visuals from the movie, set to Johann Johannsson's
haunting "Part Five."
The movie looked like a mixture of Saving
Private Ryan and Independence Day; a reinvention
the alien invasion genre.
Or so we thought.
In reality, Battle: Los Angeles earned poor
ratings for a reason.
Roger Ebert gave the film one half of a star
and called it "ugly and stupid", continuing,
"If you attend this crap with friends who
admire it, tactfully inform them they are
idiots."
The trailer was another story.
It was so good, in fact, that two years later,
Edge of Tomorrow copied it shot-for-shot and
even used another Johann Johannsson song as
its soundtrack—only this time, the movie
actually delivered on its trailer's promise.
Tron: Legacy
1982's Tron acquired a cult following after
mediocre returns at the box office.
Decades after the original whiffed, the studio
tried hard to make Tron trendy—and with
their awesome trailer for Tron: Legacy, they
almost succeeded.
There are many things to love about the trailer
for Legacy: nostalgia, great music, neon junk
everywhere, and who could forget Olivia Wilde?
11 million views on YouTube proved that the
world was ready for a Tron sequel.
Until it actually came out.
USA Today summed up most reviewers' sentiments
by calling it "impenetrable and nonsensical."
Despite its excellent trailer, it failed to
win over critics or restart the franchise.
Even today, people only really remember it
for its soundtrack, and maybe that's the best
way to look at it: a two hour long Daft Punk
music video.
The Last Airbender
It seemed like the movie to that was going
to save M. Night Shyamalan from himself.
All he had to do was adapt the story of a
hit franchise, write semi-competent dialogue,
and ride the brand-recognition of The Last
Airbender all the way to the bank.
This was a slam dunk, and the trailer tricked
us into thinking he'd scored.
It had all the elements that we loved from
the cartoon show, faithfully adapted to live
action.
It even actually looked good.
And then it bombed.
At 6% on Rotten Tomatoes, The Last Airbender
is the lowest-rated Shyamalan film, and that
includes The Happening, the movie where trees
are the villains.
The Atlantic compared the film to
"A chronic illness that worsens and worsens
without ever quite proving terminal."
TIME magazine also summoned up spectres of
death, saying,
"The actors who didn't get to be in The Last
Airbender are like the passengers who arrived
too late to catch the final flight of the
Hindenburg."
Oh, the humanity.
But perhaps one fan said it best.
"I want my money back… and I actually wish
I had my hair back too."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!